good morning job last week I sing you a
song about your inflamed nervous system
using the instrumental track from Calvin
Harris's dance song summer this was a
blatant violation of copyright I just
stole it but somehow that's okay we live
in a brave new copyright world and the
solutions really aren't legal anymore
they're technologic so for the people
out there who are making content that
they're confused about copyright this is
the bizarre state of intellectual
property in the United States in four
minutes okay intellectual property is
the idea that you can own things that
are not physical objects but are still
things there are three different ways to
own intellectual property in the u.s. if
you just create something like I'm
creating this video right now that is
protected by copyright
I own this video because I made it ideas
though cannot be copyrighted they can
sometimes be patented though obviously
the idea of controlling an idea is a
little bit more weird and scary
the US government regulates patents you
have to apply for them and be granted
and finally we have trademarks where you
want to assign a symbol or a set of
words to a corporation or a prada
like the logo of McDonald's and the word
McDonald's and the phrase I'm lovin it
are all trademarked by McDonald's so
another person can't stand up a
restaurant that looks and acts and
sounds like McDonald's but isn't owned
by McDonald's the average person who
creates or enjoys creations copyright is
the most interesting one of these and
started out very simple the idea was hey
I made a bunch of words in an order and
that's I should be able to own those
words in that order and someone else
can't come along and put all those same
words in that same order and say this is
now my book and you can buy it from me
we do something that actually used to
happen all the time you make that law
you say that you have to have the rights
to make a copy of a thing and you call
it copyright simple no it's not in order
to critique a work or to critique
Society sometimes you have to use little
bits of the things that society creates
say I want to make a video on violence
in contemporary cinema I might want to
use a clip from Reservoir Dogs to help
me illustrate my point that should be
and is legal it's called fair use
basically that's the use of copyrighted
material for societal good and also has
to be inside part of another work that
could not exist in the same way without
the use of that copyrighted material
there are things that are definitely
fair use and that no one will sue you
for because any judge in their right
mind would call it fair use that doesn't
necessarily mean that it is fair use the
only person who can decide whether
something is fair use or not is a judge
just brings me to the bizarre state of
copyright today especially on YouTube
more of a technological system than it
is a legal one because there is too much
content there is no way a lawyer could
look at every single video that was
uploaded to YouTube so YouTube as like a
robotic lawyer that looks at literally
every single video that's uploaded to
YouTube and then compares it to a
library of like just a massive amount of
intellectual property every song ever
released every movie ever made every
television show ever put on TV called
Content ID and it's actually kind of a
little bit of a miracle
like what really you can do that so if I
help with that video of me talking about
violence in contemporary American cinema
and the Reservoir Dogs clip is in their
content ID will say yes there is a clip
of Reservoir Dogs and then they will
give the owner of Reservoir Dogs whoever
that is the right to do whatever they
want with that video I could do nothing
they could take the video down or the
most likely thing that they will do is
they will monetize that video for
themselves it's basically like me paying
a retroactive license for the use of
Reservoir Dogs in my video but I
shouldn't have to do that because it's
fair use so that I would dispute that
copyright claim saying that it's fair
use and then though who knows where it
goes from there actually made a whole
video about it on Hanks channel you can
watch but this is why I can basically
steal Calvin Harris's song and not worry
about it because now I get to pay a
retroactive license to Calvin Harris I
don't get to monetize that video Calvin
Harris gets the money but at least this
way I don't have to worry about trying
to like make a deal with Calvin Harris's
record label at freaking 10 o'clock at
night on a Thursday but the big point
here is that this is not the best
solution it's not the most legal
solution it's not the fairest solution
what it is is the most possible solution
really the only possible solution and
frankly it's kind of cool I get to
violate copyright without having to
worry that my YouTube channels gonna get
taken down YouTube gets to not be sued
out of existence and rights holders get
another alternate revenue stream so that
they could have bigger and more fancy
yacht parties John I'll see you on
Tuesday